BILL LUAN: My name
is Bill Luan.
I'm working for Developer
Relations of Google.
I'm the country lead for China
and the Great China region.
I'm very glad that you can
join us for this very
interesting program, the
featured GDGs along with
Google I/O.
And along with me is
Sting Chen, the
co-manager of GDG Shanghai.
And today, we will share with
you the experience that he is
having by managing GDG Shanghai
with many interesting
programs and so on.
So again, I'm very glad that you
can join us, and welcome.
And so, hello, Sting, and I'm
very glad that you can come to
Google to join us.
What brought you here?
STING CHEN: Thank you.
I'm very glad that you come
here and represent GDG
Shanghai to Google headquarters
and share some
experience.
BILL LUAN: OK.
We are very glad you are here.
So, we will share with our
audience today the
experience you have.
Shanghai GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
They have written many programs,
especially in the
past year, that Sting
has involved in
organizing many programs.
And let's look at the slides.
Here's a quick introduction
of GDG Shanghai.
And so, Sting, could you explain
to our audience a
little bit of history
of GDG Shanghai?
STING CHEN: GDG Shanghai is
created four years before, and
GDG Shanghai is one of the
largest GDGs in China.
It has a lot of programs.
We try to share knowledge and
connect the people, and also
cooperate with other GDGs, such
as Hangzhou and Beijing.
And we hold more events,
some of [?  ?]
Series event, and have
a great brand.
We're also connected to other
communities, such as TopGeek,
PMCamp, OpenERP, and more
than 10 communities.
BILL LUAN: OK, great, yeah.
And thank you for a
lot of hard work.
I know organizing events is not
easy, and especially, a
lot of times you depend on
volunteers and have to
overcome a lot of
difficulties--
logistic, planning, and so on.
Like, myself, with organizing a
lot of events for Google, I
know it's a lot of hard work.
So thank you for all the efforts
making the developer
community very robust
in Shanghai.
In terms of events, let's look
at the events you have run.
You have many, many events, as
we can see on the slides, and
maybe you can tell us a little
bit about all the recent
events, especially showing
on the slides.
STING CHEN: Yeah.
We try to understand our
audience, what knowledge they
should know, they
want to know.
So we have a lot of
programs for them.
One of these is Software
Engineering Salon.
Every software engineer has a
lot of work to do, but if the
management is not so good,
the project will delay.
So how to solve this kind of
problem is a common problem.
Even you use Python, Java, or
other program languages, they
also needed to learn more
Google experiences.
So we invited some people from
the greater company.
They share some very good
teamwork, team building, and
problem solving experience.
BILL LUAN: OK, sounds great.
And the event just happened
this past quarter, right?
STING CHEN: Yeah.
BILL LUAN: And was this program
run by Shanghai GDG
along with other local
communities?
STING CHEN: Yes, right.
BILL LUAN: OK.
And so, that's the first one.
What about the Data Analysis
Conference?
STING CHEN: We found out there
are a lot of Google Analytics
users, but a lot of people
confused, though, with the new
Google Analytics version,
because it is more complicated
than before.
I used the Google Analytics
about seven years.
I also think the new version
is complicated, and I spent
some time to know it.
BILL LUAN: That's awful.
We should do a better job in
terms of doing better training
for the users.
I understand this conference is
first time you guys cover
about Google Analytics
in China?
STING CHEN: Yeah.
BILL LUAN: And among all the
GDGs that I have been working
with, we have never done topics
on Analytics, so I'm
very glad, actually, that you
organized the event and
covered that topic.
How was the users' reaction?
Do they like the content?
STING CHEN: The interesting
thing is there are more kind
of audience--
product managers,
some operation
managers, and some engineers.
They also like this kind of
topic, because they can learn
how to use the new version
Google Analytics, and they
also found that there are more
programs in their older
version or new version
Google Analytics.
They learn more tips.
Very good.
BILL LUAN: OK, yeah.
So, I hope that we can do
similar future trainings on
Google Analytics, do more
of that in the future.
So again, thank you for
organizing that.
And then, as the slides show,
everybody can see that they
have a Python conference that
Sting have involved organizing
along with the GDG community.
And I thought that was a very
interesting one, too.
And you, I understand, are the
organizer for the first ever
nationwide Python conference
in China, right?
STING CHEN: Yeah.
BILL LUAN: Tell us more
about that experience.
STING CHEN: I'm a Python
programmer from seven years
before, but we also have a very
small community, and we
share knowledge, and we talk
about some technologies.
We wish we had a national Python
community conference,
but we cannot find
some support.
Fortunately, we found Bill
Luan tell Guido our
[? expectation ?].
BILL LUAN: Yeah.
I actually knew that being the
Python inventor, Guido Rossum
is also a Googler today, and
of course, he was very glad
when I asked him to provide
support to your conference.
And I understood he taped a
greeting video for you, right?
STING CHEN: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
Guido.
BILL LUAN: You played
his video at
the conference, right?
STING CHEN: Yeah.
BILL LUAN: Was the audience
surprised?
STING CHEN: Everybody was so
excited to view Guido.
BILL LUAN: As the inventor,
father of Python, as a
representative Google, give
you a talk, right?
STING CHEN: Mm hm.
BILL LUAN: And that Python, I
understand that was a long
event, a whole day
long, right?
Or multiple days?
One day or two days event?
STING CHEN: Two days event.
BILL LUAN: Yeah, it's
multiple days.
Two days event, right?
STING CHEN: More than 700 people
come to the conference,
and more than 400 people
view online.
BILL LUAN: I see.
Wow.
OK.
So hopefully, you will
do that again.
I'm sure I will get more
support from Guido.
STING CHEN: Oh, we will
hold this this year.
BILL LUAN: OK, terrific.
Yeah.
And you also done HTML5 CodeJam,
the other programs
that you involved.
Could you maybe a little
bit introducing of
these to our audience?
STING CHEN: This is 36 hours
event, where there are more
than 10 teams come
to one place and
programming by HTML5.
So they submit their product
finally, and we'll have some
people to evaluate
the products and
give some bonus prize.
Very good.
BILL LUAN: Interesting.
And how about the community
managers training?
What's that?
STING CHEN: We found that we
don't have very stable
volunteers come to these
communities.
Some people want to join the
organizers, but they don't
know how to do this.
So we try to tell people, if you
want to join the community
organizers, you can learn
something from
the successful people.
So, we invite more than 20
community people to share
their experience.
BILL LUAN: I see.
This is a very good, yeah.
STING CHEN: Yeah.
BILL LUAN: Because even I know
that working with GDGs across
China, and along with our
program managing team, working
with global GDG communities, I
know this also always has been
a big challenge in terms of have
volunteers continuously
working with the community and
organizing enough events.
So, yeah, I'm glad that you
organized a training for that.
Very good.
So thank you, again, for
a lot of these efforts.
And also, I know you have a lot
of things in store for the
second half of this
year, right?
And would you please share with
our audience some of your
thinking, ideas?
So let's look at slides.
The plan that Sting had with
GDG Shanghai, what are you
going to do in the
second half?
STING CHEN: Yeah.
We have a very interesting event
is about learn seven new
languages in seven weeks, such
as Go, Dart, Python, Ruby,
NodeJs, and other languages.
BILL LUAN: Oh, nice.
I even noticed you have
Dart on there.
STING CHEN: Yeah.
BILL LUAN: We just launched our
new developers.google.com,
our new dev site, this past week
or two, right before I/O.
And I know that Dart content
and Dart training is one of
the highest viewed material,
and lots of interest in the
industry to learning these new
languages from Google.
And I'm very glad that you
actually [INAUDIBLE]
have Dart training on it.
That's nice.
STING CHEN: I think
every [? team ?]
should learn more
new languages.
BILL LUAN: Yeah, very nice.
But what about college tour?
STING CHEN: College tour is
a very interesting tour.
We tried to share the knowledge
in colleges, so we
pick Android technologies.
In Shanghai, there are more
greater universities, and we
pick five, one-by-one, to
hold the college tour.
In another three months or so,
we hold three college events
in three very great
universities.
BILL LUAN: OK.
How did you find the connections
in those
universities?
Did you work with the students
who are interested in Google
technologies, or do you work
with the professors there?
STING CHEN: We try to connect
to professors.
But we found students is
better, so we connected
directly to students.
There are some clubs
in colleges.
BILL LUAN: Oh, yeah, OK.
Clubs interested in these
technologies, Google
technologies, open
web technologies.
STING CHEN: Yeah, and the
students are very
[? excited. ?]
We can help them to create
a very great event.
So they do everything, such as
the poster, the logo design,
and to find a place.
BILL LUAN: Nice.
STING CHEN: Yeah, very good.
BILL LUAN: Now you got a lot
of volunteers, right?
Work with you.
Terrific.
And so, I see on your slides,
you have a PyCon again
planned, right?
STING CHEN: Yes.
BILL LUAN: And this year, you're
going to do more than
in one city?
You're going to have
two cities now.
STING CHEN: Yeah.
Well, we think one plan is
have this in two cities,
because this has been
a two days weekend.
If people work five days and
come to conference two days,
then [? working ?]
five days they were
very tired.
So we try to use one day in one
city, but continually to
view the conference online and
expand this event to Beijing.
Beijing has a lot of
Python programmers.
BILL LUAN: And they couldn't go
to Shanghai last year, so
by doing this this year,
hopefully you will reach out
to more people, more
developers.
Very nice.
And of course, then, DevFestX.
Globally, Developer Relations
work with a lot of developer
communities.
We are organizing events,
anything that is more than
half a day long, have at lease
three topics, we're branding
them as DevFestX.
And so, hopefully you will
organize one for Shanghai GDG.
STING CHEN: OK, no problem.
BILL LUAN: And we will support
you as much as we can, and
hopefully it will
be successful.
So great, yeah.
One thing I would like to ask
you about the events you run,
in terms of you using events,
you share the knowledge with
developers.
Maybe you can tell us one or
two stories about in these
past events, what really
worked well in
terms of shared knowledge.
And maybe you can give us
a couple of examples?
STING CHEN: Yeah.
We try to think of what
knowledge people need.
So, we use [? knowledge ?]
to attract the people come to
a conference or events, such
as we think that they are a lot
of people converting from
engineers to product managers,
so they also think about our
knowledge, but they cannot find
a very good channel to
learn more skills and tips.
So we find Google Analytics is
a very good knowledge to
attract the people to come here,
and then these connect
them to share knowledge.
So we have the very good
Google Analytics event.
This event has more than 150
people come to the conference.
BILL LUAN: And the speakers,
they are from where?
STING CHEN: The speakers
come to [INAUDIBLE]
for mobile company.
He is a translator for
a famous book.
Another is a famous website,
[INAUDIBLE]
He's very good.
BILL LUAN: And they have
used Analytics before?
STING CHEN: Yeah.
They have more experience.
BILL LUAN: Yeah.
I like it that you leverage
the technology experts in
different companies,
come to our GDG
community, share the knowledge.
A lot of people see the examples
of how other people
did, what other companies
use Google technologies.
It should be very good
inspiration for them to pick
up new technology, or try.
So, I think that's very good.
In a lot of aspects, it's
actually better.
You have these people's personal
testimonies, use
their own examples, then a
Google speaker to tell the
story, right?
So I really like it that you
have the speakers from other
companies to share
the knowledge.
One other thing that I'm very
interested in is that you do a
lot of things connected
with universities.
So, as the slides, we have seen
here that you have run
many programs at universities
in the past.
Could you introduce a little
bit of what did you do in
terms of working with
these universities?
STING CHEN: Yeah.
And the first thing is very
hard, but we have a very good
channel, because Tonji
University has more students
join the compete last year.
They get bigger prizes.
So we connect these people,
tell them we need to come
together and have the very
good event in Tonji
University.
They say very good,
so [INAUDIBLE]
BILL LUAN: This was happening
this year, right?
This past [INAUDIBLE].
STING CHEN: Yeah.
BILL LUAN: OK, in April.
And how about Jaio
Tong University?
I know that's a very
good school.
Lot of computer science
students, right?
STING CHEN: Yeah.
BILL LUAN: What did
you do there?
STING CHEN: I also come from
Shanghai Jaio Tong University.
BILL LUAN: Oh, you graduate
from there?
STING CHEN: Yeah.
There are more people who want
to learn new technologies, so
we have a half-day event for
Shanghai Jaio Tong University,
and we have four speakers
in this event.
[INAUDIBLE]
[? Center ?]
have more support
for this event.
We tell them why people need to
learn mobile development,
why need to choose Android,
and how to do develop and
Android, some technologies so
the people are very glad.
And we have a long session
asking question and answer.
People is very good.
BILL LUAN: And where were
the speakers from?
Where did you get speakers
for those events?
STING CHEN: It's very
interesting.
[INAUDIBLE]
from the training company.
They can describe why you
should learn Android.
They describe their
dream to students.
BILL LUAN: So they're
very professional.
STING CHEN: Yes.
BILL LUAN: They know
what to do, yeah.
Are they based in Shanghai,
this company?
STING CHEN: Yeah, it's
based in Shanghai.
Another is our GDG Shanghai
organizer.
BILL LUAN: OK, good.
Right, very nice.
STING CHEN: [INAUDIBLE]
BILL LUAN: The other things I
would like to ask you about is
your collaboration with
other GDGs in China.
I understand for the very
first time, when we were
actually beta testing and
launching the Google Hangout,
that you guys in Shanghai
and the GDG
Hangzhou collaborate together.
[INAUDIBLE] joined Hangout
session, right?
Tell us about that experience.
STING CHEN: Shanghai GDG has a
lot of connections with more
communities and experts,
but Hangzhou
don't have more speakers.
So sometimes, we try to connect
the two places.
We share the knowledge
by Google Hangout.
The speakers, such as
[INAUDIBLE], he's a very good
Go lang expert.
He has a big Go lang
presentation, and we use
Google Hangout to share
this knowledge.
Video and audio, too.
BILL LUAN: You mean
the Go language?
STING CHEN: Yeah, Go language.
So Hangzhou also can learn
this by video.
BILL LUAN: I see.
So [INAUDIBLE]
use Hangout, and your guys'
events happen in Shanghai.
The speaker was in Shanghai,
but the GDG Hangzhou, they
dial in, they watch online?
STING CHEN: Yes, right.
BILL LUAN: And can they ask
questions and your speakers in
Shanghai be able to answer?
STING CHEN: They can
ask questions.
BILL LUAN: Live,
through video?
STING CHEN: Yeah, live.
BILL LUAN: How's the speed?
How is the quality,
the video quality?
I always worry about the
cross-city, link together, you
may have a problem.
Did that work at all?
STING CHEN: Unfortunately, we
found the quality is not so
good, because our computer is
far away from the speaker.
So we use a mobile phone
nearby the speaker.
Solved the problems.
And later, we find we shouldn't
use audio [? line ?]
to connect to computer.
BILL LUAN: That's a good
lesson, right.
It's very important to have good
audio equipment connects
to the PC so that the audio
is clear, people can hear.
STING CHEN: Yeah, noise
is very clear.
BILL LUAN:, So you guys
are going to try
again in the future?
This is very interesting.
STING CHEN: Yeah.
In fact, we're trying Shanghai
Jiao Tong University in the
college tour for Android
development.
BILL LUAN: Using Hangout.
STING CHEN: Yeah, Hangout.
And I invite [? HEIFI ?]
GDG to join.
They just learned how to do
this, and it's very good.
I think this audio
is very good.
And we published the
video to tudou.com.
We use [INAUDIBLE]
BILL LUAN: For audience that
don't know what tudou.com that
Sting referred to, it's almost
like a YouTube of China, where
people can upload the video
clips, so they do that
locally, hopefully getting
a better speed, right?
STING CHEN: Yes.
BILL LUAN: In terms of
watching the video.
Yeah, so I'm glad that you
actually tried that.
Hopefully in the future, we'll
do more cross-GDG events, so
that GDG communities in
different cities, we can get
them work together, learning
from each other.
This would be very good.
One other thing I would like you
to talk about is the GDG
community in Shanghai connects
with lots of other
communities, right?
As on the slides, everybody can
see GDG Shanghai has been
working with many local
developer communities.
And a lot of those names are
probably not well known
outside of Shanghai or
outside of China.
So it's interesting, maybe
you can explain to
us, what are these?
STING CHEN: In Shanghai,
there are more
communities, such as TopGeek.
I worked for TopGeek community
about two years.
BILL LUAN: Is it big?
How many developers there?
STING CHEN: More than 2,000.
BILL LUAN: More than 2,000!
Wow!
OK.
Big community.
STING CHEN: Because [? it ?]
[? has ?]
[? more ?] big conference.
Different areas, so it
has a lot of members.
BILL LUAN: And PMCamp,
that's the one
you just did Analytic--
no, that's the one you
did the programming
model training, right?
STING CHEN: Yeah.
This is a product manager
community.
It's also more than 2,000 people
in this community.
BILL LUAN: And what
about the others?
Any other notable ones?
STING CHEN: Such as CPyUG
is a Python community.
ECUG before is Ur lang but
now is for Go lang.
BILL LUAN: OK.
So it's Go language.
STING CHEN: Yeah, Go language
[INAUDIBLE]
And HTML5 Dream Factory is
another HTML5 community.
BILL LUAN: I see.
And what's the AgileTour?
Is that a Agile model thing?
STING CHEN: Yeah.
Agile is a programming model.
BILL LUAN: A programming
management model.
STING CHEN: Management model.
BILL LUAN: OK.
Would you be able to invite
maybe, say, some of the
speakers in those communities
come to Shanghai
GDG to give a talk?
STING CHEN: In fact, more good
speakers want to share their
knowledge to more areas
and more communities.
You find them and tell them who
are you, and why you can
help them to do this.
[? We're allowed ?]
to do this.
BILL LUAN: I see.
So they may be willing
to come?
STING CHEN: Yeah.
BILL LUAN: And so if you
organize a Shanghai GDG event,
maybe invite some of these from
PMCamp, TopGeek, as the
speaker, but speak to
the GDG community.
STING CHEN: Yeah.
BILL LUAN: And because we have
a huge, like, 700, 800 people
now that you can have those
speakers talk to
our members, right?
STING CHEN: Right.
BILL LUAN: And hopefully, you
can maybe do some of those.
And we talked about DevFestX.
Maybe in the future, you can
do events, combine some of
these communities together.
Do a joint event,
make it bigger.
STING CHEN: Yeah.
Well, we try to invite more good
speakers from different
communities or different
companies.
BILL LUAN: And make
things fun, more
interesting, exciting.
STING CHEN: Right, exactly.
BILL LUAN: OK, that's all.
What we're trying to do, make
learning technologies,
including Google technologies,
fun and exciting.
And hopefully, this little
sharing of Shanghai GDG's
experience will be helpful
to all of you.
And thank you for your
time to come join us.
And Sting, thank you for sharing
your experience.
And welcome to Google, and enjoy
your stay at Google.